very happy to have as my guest for
another one of these it face to face
interviews somebody whose work I've been
reading for really quite a long time
decades and I've drawn on quite a bit
Chris Gill for those who don't know him
from from sort of an academic stoic
context he how many books have you ever
the ones on stake would be a stereo
system would be structured self in
headland thought that's that's not
entirely about stasis but a lot of it is
and then there's my Murchison radius
plantation introduction commentary on
the first six books they are meditations
I mean you know and also I did another
book on Galen man stairs relationship
between you know galenic instead
psychology so though in recent years I
have been working quite a lot on the
stage you know in a way when I think
about it so yours you're sort of one of
the interlocutors in the important
debates read articles and Gil says this
yeah so yeah articles yes
a lot of that would be in articles
although we've also engage in rich 'red
and I had a long-running debate for a
while both in books and article form I
suppose I Richards more of a skeptic
really about the stoke theory of the
motions I'm intending to stack view of
emotions and emotional therapies but
Richards I think you should be honest I
think Richard always approaches
everything from a more Aristotelian yeah
he denies this but so that is actually a
perfect lead-in for talking about your
current book project in terms of
stoicism and virtue I think since when
I think your virtual yes yeah yeah I'm
writing County writing a book which is
going to be first of all my reading of
circa thix and that the key themes in
statics and going to try and tackle the
matter of the relationship between
nature and and ethics has come back to
that and then the other aspect of the
book which will be quite a fair bit of
the book will be talking about how how
stoicism can contribute more than it
does to contemporary virtue ethics
because I think yes there's been a lot
of attention to Aristotle Aristotle was
lost Robin Williams Anita McIntyre was
the great influence yeah but I think in
many ways
the stove's more congenial fires and
more suitable for engagement and I want
to bring that out yeah and I mean I
think that their theories their views
about the relationship in virtue and
Happiness their views about ethical
development to propel appropriation of
like a thesis and indeed their views
about about ethical development and
guidance these are all really useful
ideas that that although that we've been
making use of them in the state stoicism
today and modern tourism area haven't
been so much brought in to debating in
theoretical virtue ethics it seems that
I mean McIntyre is sort of
representative of this in after virtue
yeah it's the Stoics essentially as
deontologist prefiguring Contin and
there are you know themes of freedom
through rationality and the duties so
there is you can see how he got to that
that reading but it seems I think I
don't agree with that I mean I think I
could continue about how he got it and
Kant is relatively polite about the
staring yeah
Lincoln doesn't like well he doesn't
he's putting forward a completely
different moral philosophy it is much
more logical and it's much more
law and so on and he's not he doesn't
either doesn't understand or rejects the
ancient idea of eudaimonia happiness
yeah he treats it as being identical
with his idea of happiness which is a
much more well I feel like a much more
modern idea feeling good their
satisfaction satisfaction and
supplications yeah
but no I think I think he's wrong I
think McIntyre is rolling I think the
Stoics are very well I tell you talk
about the mistakes and McIntyre I think
the stoic soul for a problem that
McIntyre has I tell you what the problem
is the Mac in the house and people have
pointed out this about his book he says
we've got to get back to the more virtue
ethics approach yeah but he also says
that you can't have virtue ethics an
issue have a culture right a culture and
a community and a community in which the
virtues are taught and practiced and
that they're in embedded in the culture
and people and and that's a very
Aristotelian view that's that's a better
you know that he's right the autism
hurts
Tinian view and it's his view but it
leaves him with a problem yeah and he I
didn't think he's ever such a second
three soldiers body and people still
debate about it yeah
the Stoics on the other hand the Stoics
men care that you can have a thought
about it and they won't do
just anachronistic but they thought that
you could what they believed was that we
all have the capacity to become virtuous
yeah we all have the capacity happiness
whatever our culture whatever our
society and you know they had years
about massage which they defend that now
I'll try and explain what have yous are
in a minute but but the point is once
you have Matthews that McIntyre's
approach becomes much more tenable yes
once you have a kind of more
Universalist virtue ethics that it is a
form of theof an ethics that can develop
in anything then the sort of what you
might call the MacIntyre problem
disappear do you think that well oh it
becomes you still do need to have at
least some sense of community and it
could be one well I think what sort of X
virtual right well it could but I think
the stare extinct something like this
well there's several things I think one
is that they think that all all human
beings by nature have the capacity to
form moral notions or moral rights they
also think that all human beings have
the capacity to live in whatever
environment they are and exercise a kind
of critical selectiveness
so that they they they they graduate
that they can selectively come to a
sound understanding or good if this they
did perfectly but that's possible Seneca
120 he says exactly that he says look
how do I know what the virtuous is how
do I know what this is I go in society
and I look at people I look at the
examples you know I see location or I
look at this person I look at that
person yeah I take advice and
and what he's saying there is that it
doesn't depend or having a culture that
uses ideal and doesn't depend on the
culture that necessarily would overall
describe as you know a virtuous culture
yeah I mean goodness me Seneca in a
culture that anyone could describe as a
virtuous cultivate yeah he thinks that
people any whatever your context you
have that inbuilt apology not not that
you're given a kind of moral framework
but did you have the capacity to develop
it I think that's a very interesting
view and I think that that means all
that provides an explanation of how you
can have a culture that is you know
doesn't isn't necessarily isn't as
McIntosh saw the ancient Greece as you
saw medieval culture this is ideal yeah
these ideals of Athens full century
Athens and 16th Terrace yes that's
always puzzled me and I've seen some
people provide some explanation so I
mean Aristotle is he is in Athens
getting to observe things as a resident
alien yes very briefly with Alexander to
Athens we know that he he and his
students did all those reviews of Greek
constitutions and you know we don't have
we only have the Athenian Constitution
be very interesting to have all these
but he says in the politics
none of the existing Greek city-states
are remotely close to things
lots of it yes and so this this emphasis
in there it seems rather strange to come
from somebody who is you know very
closely connected although opposed to
someone I agree to Alexander who's
trying to create this you know new
cultural sphere as well military
conquests and who doesn't belong this
you couldn't even although I seen on me
because he property yes yes where do you
think this this insistence polis as
something that just has to be well I
think it was just probably just seemed
to him self evidence that he was the
best
and actually I mean there's a truth to
it I mean it was far and away the most
the best form of political framework no
it was better than tyranny better than
monarchy but but but I think yeah I
think he assumed the police later and
assume deposits ideal Republic but it's
still it's a nopales and I think but I
think the because the politics is quite
a complicated work and and and in the in
the politics he does talk about an ideal
yeah which is quite different from any
of the you know the policy
yeah place that he knew so so in a way
aristotle doesn't really assume that
people think he talks about the fact
you've gotta have more facts yeah and
they do the one you had why but he
doesn't I didn't think Aristotle really
has this smack into my back in
Tyrian like view that the culture he
which were brought up has to be pretty
damn good I think there are certain
ratios of screw fair more I think that
was a McIntyre and remember McIntyre is
a sociology is yes it's early you know
first he was an official yes name is
Kathleen
he was a Marxist or a Democritus yeah oh
these are all these are very much
organic society theories yeah very much
so I think I was a host of good things
that you know you need to develop
ethically you need good qualities of
nature
you need needing a good upbringing and
you need a good education but I don't I
think he's probably in reality pretty
open about how that can be obtained yeah
I'm the Stoics of course go one step
further
yeah they will just say look you know
you could be much more radical about it
we've all got the ability to learn you
know we've all got it
as such as as human beings and of course
they're much more radical in many ways
you know they believe in a brotherhood
of humankind and and they they they
believe that we're related not only to a
society but the cosmos series so there
are lots of quite radical ways that they
they they introduce a broader broader
frame let me ask you another question
then about sort of the stoic ethics
framework yes so it's very clear the
ancient starts a strict separation
between animal life and human life in
terms of rationality the lower exists
for the sake of the higher given what we
know through you know observation of
animal behavior can you might say to not
deduce but what we can infer that he was
willing I mean yes we're all to say I
think I think that's that's clear now
but we don't want to say that an oyster
has how does how does that work then
with if we're thinking about stoic
virtue ethics today is it like a
straddle them well let's think about
that I think I think I
starik Treatment of Animals ovules
and I think it is one of the problematic
for us it is one of the problematic
regions of Stoicism
Isle I am an admirer obsessed I don't I
don't I can't I don't have a completely
normal critical view yeah I think
everything is rosy and I think their
view that the pig exists only for the
sake of us is protein repellent action
although it is across the view it is our
view it's benign agenda but it's not a
view I'm ah I mean it's interesting it
was changing yes yes I mean I think it's
very easy for somehow to transpose back
to the ancient world what we have done
yeah and the fact is there's a huge gulf
between the worlds of I mean virtually
everyone in the ancient world was
carrying it as an animal husbandry yeah
in a much more sustainable way yes but
but you know these animals they had a
lot yeah I had a decent loving yeah and
and you know they weren't no natural
chickens or battery Peter batteries
we've done yeah we've done that we've
done that with our supposed concern and
I think that the so I think that you
know it's important not to to to just
transpose that back the other thing I
think that's the other strand of
Stoicism though I think is much more
valuable here is they're thinking about
nature as a whole and as I mentioned a
minute seminar that the I mean they
think of nature as providential and Toby
said this too ok so what does nature's
prophet in charity me well nature
spirituality means
you you care for every element in nature
yeah you want every element in nature to
have its own life the air the water you
know the animals the plants that's what
this Rosetta connection to the gods
starik stearic theology and the way in
which nature promulgated this or
promoted this the way in which nature
exercised its property on geology was to
build in to all animals including us
certain basic motives or instincts
namely the motive to look after your
your own constitution or the
Constitution I won't go on your nature
and to defend yourself so you maintain
your life and secondly they built in the
desire to procreate and also to care for
others of your own kind and so do they
and they took animals non-human animals
as a paradigm in this respect even among
the animals you have here this is the
voice of nature yeah so so nature so
there's this other side to stearic
thinking about animals that animals
other animals are emblematic of the
benevolence and Providenciales of nature
now that's quite a different strength
animals convenience but they do say
things like that but but you know I
don't we don't agree we shouldn't I
think agree with them on that what I
think the stick should have said Here I
am being interventionists but yeah I
think I think we will be consistent for
the Stoics to have said because we human
beings are rational and we have
capacities that other animals don't
yeah we'll come back to that restaurant
yeah but but but but because of that we
have it if you're like a duty of care
towards other animals and towards the
natural environment well that's what I
was it that that leads into what I was
asking
Providence is understood by the Stoics
in epictetus he says that we I forget
the exact phrase but we're because of
we're rational we're called to
participate in Providence in a very
different way yes yes animal creation
and it seems like yes this would fit
here yeah this is not fit with that no I
think I think this would fit they didn't
they didn't develop this they're not at
least in Cicero's work but they could
have done so it was too late now for us
to answer that is a glass because I
think I mean I think as I mentioned I'm
writing a book on stoic ethics in its
modern contribution but this is a
constituent process it's more a dialogue
yeah between our world our ethical world
and the past and I think there's many
ways in which racism to us a virtue
ethics its Universalist but that's
coherent in its account at the
relationship between virtue and ethics
it's fun a fine theory of ethical
development innovation since on but but
also there are some things on which we -
we can learn or stearic we can see how
the stakes could have improved their own
enforcer yeah by taking on board all
right gears oh by or by modifying we
were we're just talking about that a
little bit earlier Tim and I Tim
confessed that he when he first started
out yet a very strong attraction to
classical utilitarianism yes I said well
you know if you think about the range of
the indifference it makes good sense
much of the time to use something like a
utilitarian calculus probably not in
terms of hedonism something that
attempts to maximize positive outcomes
it could make sense for everything
that's not strictly speaking we're
trying to do that for some things at
least right yes
well sort of yes no really I mean I
think I think what they I don't think
they were ever attempt
we would see as utilitarian maximizing
view I dig the sterics I think what they
thought was something slightly different
was that their view is something that
situated as eddie per any given person
is in a certain social situation in a
certain life situation yeah political
situation there are certain short
there's certain decisions which are
properly made as regards indifference
this is very much incentive of you you
have in sisters on duty yeah so what you
we need to learn is how to select
appropriately between the indifference
which indifference we allocate to which
person which difference we Alec
preferred indifference we allocate to
ourselves which to other people on what
grounds in what context
so I think that they here they are
closer to Aristotle over it so actually
so I think it's it's less I don't I
don't think they think is that to you
you can somehow reach a virtuous view by
kind of maximizing in because how do I
mean how would it work for them okay
well it's basically works which in turn
is although it's probably a Chinese but
what they would want to say well hang on
you know I mean which which okay which
what does it mean to maximize what did
we get a vaccine and then are you gonna
maximize wells well how's it you know
how's that we're gonna maximize
reputation are we gonna make you
maximize health well like the health is
somewhat slightly differ but you do have
the problem of measuring that against
the others so comes for health we
certainly couldn't maximize them as
people were going to pay for it well yes
it's a complex and it's complex matter I
mean how healthier is not just of how
much you pay but really so it's a
complex matter but I think they just
were not attracted to
the maximization model and I think in
some ways with good reason and
utilitarianism does land itself
you know there's algorithms which are
produced yeah and you know a lot of them
they just don't work they certainly
don't work if you think about ethics in
a more individual way which is largely
you know how virtue ethics is conceived
so but but there is this element in
common that the sterics do think that it
is perfectly reasonable for us to aim to
to obtain and to obtain for others and
for souls prepared indifference of
course yeah who wouldn't want to be
healthier Cato actually says that's
that's where the Stoics differ from Aris
know is that you're not bearing upon
those those indifference you can't
exercise wisdom yes yes so in that sense
but of course each enterin yzma has much
more than that
they really do you know you to
deterrence so from Bentham to to profit
they do want to make us say so you know
calculus oh boy it's my legs I was
thinking about the Dylan and and
defending utilitarianism he really turns
with two latarian isn't something quite
different individual I mean the one
really great advantage I think of
utilitarianism is that it does stress
that other people have a claim on yes
and anything and and and we should
exercise this we should respond to this
claim in a way that is not you know
excessively partial but of course that
then you immediately get the problem
what does that mean yeah and how do you
look after your kids and look after the
play you know it gets it's problematic
but I think that they that I can see why
utilitarianism you know captured the
the moral imagination in the 19th
century oh and of course it is a
philosophy that it is a philosophy that
goes well with the kind of social action
corporate statement that was coming out
in the 19th century Louis is very
different you know it is interesting
although III get a lot of people who
want to attack utilitarianism because
they assume it's automatically going to
lead to you know an American socialism
as a dirty word in other countries yes
Bentham himself was a major advocate of
the free market because he conceived of
it as a useful way of you know
maximizing utility but then he ensoniq
to mercantilism yes in a previous way of
doing things he hadn't actually seen how
bad the free market can be it was you
know there were crashes yeah oh and and
it was in some ways it was worse because
you know the banks would go to the wall
ya know Dickens's bank collapses people
shooting themselves and yeah no safety
net didn't really have much of a safety
net without the Corning limit it was
very moralistic and very politically
conscientious but I mean II actually did
some terrible things I mean they did you
either yeah I mean what there was of a
safety net could often be quite bad to
fall into well yes all of the poor house
I suppose they were beginning they were
developing their safety safety net but
much of it just depended on Harris -
yeah it's not a very good basis yeah
well so when is when do you think the
the book project will be finished well
it'll be finished when it's ready yeah I
think I will probably finish the sort of
reading of ancient state ethics sometime
possibly this calendar year and then
I'll probably be spending most of next
year thinking about the the dialogue
with with modern ethics but who knows
books have their own books right
themselves I now as per below we have
said you know they they do books have a
way of writing themselves really and
there is there is a truth to that but
but I shall say yeah I think that's not
impossible
and yeah it's just one shouldn't get
over you know a book is just possible
conversation yeah alright so I imagine
my viewers are not mostly academics yes
so they may not know that oftentimes of
academic books
parts of it are you could say shopped
out ahead of time in terms of confidence
well it might be yes I've done I've done
a number of preliminary and actually
it's fed directly into mind as I've been
writing it it's fed directly into my
work on the stair can book I usually and
it's fed to rate now what I've said
about happiness is really informed by
what I've been thinking about happiness
so in that sense yes I mean it's rather
sometimes think of how paradox over it
is I mean if I write this book if I'm
lucky you know kept seven hundred people
will go by it and yet seven thousand
people maybe you know as it were at this
moment reading the thoughts I brought
about happiness right and just know that
they're my thoughts aesthetic thoughts
present it gives you you know it does
give you a chance to to check on do yeah
to what do you want to try and get
things as righteous as possible ready so
so it has but but also I am writing yes
right well is there anything else you'd
like to say its final four no I don't
think so I think I think it's I think as
I say that the with the book I think
it's going to be yes I want to I want to
show how serious is impart of
contemporary academic debate as well as
you know
bit of a tour yeah and also how that
could really help us think more
profoundly about virtue and happiness
about ethical education I divide ethics
in nature I think that it can help us
and it can help our understanding of
Stoicism so yeah that is my immediate
thank you thanks very much for that for
giving me this interview and I'm sure
people are going to have a lot of great
questions and and things like that and
the comments that say that's really a
treat for me to be able to sit down with
you and talk with you about this as well
well it's really great pleasure to meet
you
you